hallo leute ich ist wieder einmal wander
und willkommen zum vierten remis das
tagebuch fällt auseinander alte
durchhalte durch glaube letztes mal hat
es nicht besonders geendet deswegen
machen wir einfach weiter fällt echt
auseinander 21 25 der 2005 hallo teddy
ich habe mich heute richtig mit so viel
gestritten
sie ist auch so eine blöde kuh ich für
beleidigungen drauf hatte ich habe heute
meine tagebuch bekommen
würde jetzt gerne ein loch graben und im
boden versinken
das ist so scheiße jetzt wisst ihr halt
wann ich meine tage bekommen habe bitte
und jetzt lasst euer gehirn irgendeine
erinnerung weg damit ihr diese
informationen speichert habe ich gerne
gemacht
ich verstehe mich mit jedem aus der
klasse und meine pickel gehen langsam
weg ist sophie wirklich schöner als ich
dann wirst bald ist sophie wirklich
schöner als ich 25 5 2005 hier steht
sogar die uhrzeit 00 uhr 14
da steht hatte die who are you speak in
englischen auf ich glaube es liegt daran
dass meine tage bekomme bis jetzt neuer
wandel ich bin jetzt erwachsen und
spreche englisch weißt du was andré hat
mir im internet eine komische
liebeserklärung gemacht
andrä aber ich weiß dass marvin das war
so blöd kann nur was glaubt ihr
eigentlich wer ist sophie ist genauso
blöd wie immer und ich habe bei angriffs
geschlafen paar helfern herzlich hatte
angriff machen wir mal weiter
27 05 2005 heute hat sich meine
vermutung bestätigt ich wusste es aber
sowieso
es war den ganzen tag warm bis zum
umfallen und mamas schrauben wurden aus
dem fuß rausgenommen bei vanessa meine
mama zumal das bein gebrochen und da
wurden wohl hier die schrauben wieder
rausgenommen noch etwas was er da
hingeht speichert und irgendeine schöner
inneren rausschmeißt
dafür stehe ich mit meinem namen haben
auch sie schöne erinnerungen wollen sie
ganz schnell loswerden
keine sorge hören sie sich wenn das
tagebuch an und sie kriegen
informationen die so sinnlos und so
nutzlos sind dass sie alles vergessen
was sie bis dahin gemacht haben ja okay
leute es ist schon viel passiert ich
habe meine tage krieg die pegel sind
weniger machen wollte mich verarschen
und so weiter 30 5 2005
heute war englisch förderlich und all
die anderen
natürlich quatsch gemacht und ich und
andre haben uns gestritten wer besser
basketball spielen kann
da gab es richtig wie ohne witz ich bin
echt ganz gut und basketball spielen
also ich kann gut körbe werfen das jahr
dann wollten wir noch bildet im chat
spielen doch er konnte nichts und dann
ist er so einfach rausgegangen
das passte aber weil ich sowieso
hausaufgaben machen musste später wusste
ich nicht weiter bei den hausaufgaben
da habe ich andrea angerufen und er hat
gesagt dass mir ein blatt fehlt bei
deutsch
bei deutsch vanessa bei deutsch dann bin
ich noch zu stoppen
stop shop in shop in shop in shop
gegangen um mir ein blog zu kaufen
sonst hätte ich eine sächsin kunst schon
wieder ich habe sechs asics geschrieben
ich hätte fast 6 in kunst bekommen wenn
ich diesen blog nicht gekauft hätte
könnt ihr euch das vorstellt sex in
kunst beides
ich hoffe ihr seid auch beim nächsten
mal wieder dabei wenn ich meine tiefsten
geheimnisse mit euch teile und bis dahin
bleibt geschmeidig pvt
wir hoffen euch hat das video befallen
wenn ja dann abonniert doch den kanal
bis dann nun gebt uns euren abgetrennten
daumen nach oben